oh ouais, je suis le roi de
l'Atlantide, le vrai roi Bill Bridges, c'est
vrai, le vrai roi construit des
ponts à l'époque du roi Alin, il y
avait sept royaumes et le trident était
une malédiction sur eux,
toute la magie noire du trident se
propage, il veut mettre fin à
votre lignée à deux.
Je ne sais pas ce qui nous attend mais nous
ne pouvons pas laisser à nos enfants un monde sans
[Musique]
j'espère que tu sais que j'ai un tas de conneries de King
à refaire pour me
déchaîner  oh ouais, je suis le roi de
[Musique] Le
vrai roi de l'Atlantide construit
des ponts, la magie du début du tridon se
propage, il veut mettre fin à la
lignée, nous ne pouvons pas laisser à nos enfants un
monde sans
espoir, merci